All right. Buckle up, everybody. I'm about
to be called a racist. Unfortunately,
there are people who are going to listen
to this segment and call me a racist,
and that's sad. But I encourage you to listen
to this entire segment all the way through.
I've been telling you all along that when
Joe Biden does things that I don't like
or that fail to be truly left, I'm going to point
them out to you. I'm going to call them out. And
we have the perfect prototypical example today.
President elect Joe Biden has selected Lloyd
Austin to be his secretary of defense, Lloyd
Austin is a retired four star Army general,
was previously the commander of CENTCOM, actually
was the first African-American commander of
CENTCOM and would be the first African-American
secretary of defense in American history.
Very interesting personal story from Alabama,
raised in Georgia, graduated from West Point,
two master's degrees, including an MBA. Really
interesting guy. No shortage of intelligence,
no shortage of military and other experience
and academic experience, no doubt whatsoever.
But this is the perfect example of how a lot
of people are focusing on the identity story
at the exclusion of admitting and recognizing
that Lloyd Austin, as interesting as his career,
has been, as inspiring as I admit, being the
first black secretary of defense would be.
Lloyd Austin represents exactly the problems we're
trying to fix in government and in foreign policy
and in defense. Lloyd Austin is the prototypical
example of diversification in terms of identity
without changing any of the power structures which
partially are responsible for the problems that
make his identity as the first black secretary of
defense notable in the first place. To start with,
this is another military guy who hasn't even been
out of the military long enough, seven years,
such that he requires a congressional exemption to
even be allowed to be secretary of defense. Let me
explain that many people may not know about this.
There's a law, the National Security Act of 1947,
which requires any prospective cabinet secretary
to wait seven full years after ending active duty
in the military as a commissioned officer
before you can be in a president's cabinet.
Lloyd Austin was on active duty until 2016. Now,
I am not going to be a hypocrite. I remember
that back in twenty seventeen, I did a story
about Donald Trump's secretary of defense
selection, Jim Mattis. At the time, the title of
this video was These Democrats plus one Republican
had the balls to vote no on Trump Cabinet. Now the
title doesn't tell you about what's in the story,
but in that story I explained Jim Mattis,
Trump's pick for secretary of defense,
hasn't been out of active duty for seven years.
So Congress is going to need to issue a waiver
to get Jim Mattis in Donald Trump's
cabinet. And at the time, I said,
why the hell do we have a rule about this? If the
president can just go to Congress and get a waiver
and I'm not a hypocrite. So I have to tell you the
exact same thing today. If we have this rule from
nineteen forty seven, why not stick to it? What
is the point? If Joe Biden can just get it waived,
why do we need such a recent active duty
military person as secretary of defense?
Because the rule was meant
to disincentives choosing
recent active duty military people instead
of choosing long retired military folks
or straight up civilians for secretary of defense.
The idea being nonmilitary secretaries of defense
or or those who have a military background
but have been out of the military longer,
would be less cozy with the military, and
they would bring a more impartial approach
to sort of counterbalance the Joint Chiefs
of Staff and others within the military.
That's the whole point here. So this was a great
opportunity for Joe Biden to instead of starting
with another military officer whose was was in the
military so recently that he's got to be waved in.
Joe Biden could have started his presidency with
a return to normalcy, with civilian oversight
of military plans and actions. But he's the first
black secretary of defense. That is the story that
is being told. And then on the other side of this,
you're also putting a ton of Democrats in a really
stupid looking position because many Democrats who
will vote on this nomination opposed the waiver
for Jim Mattis in 2017. Now, they are
likely going to have to acquiesce and. OK,
Lloyd Austin. And this applies to those
in the House of Representatives as well,
confirming that they are hypocrites and
giving Republicans more ammunition than
we need to give them to quote Joe Biden.
Come on, man, this is misguided. And then
when you look specifically at Lloyd Austin's
military career, it's not good. Lloyd Austin
was the commanding general in Iraq and then
commander of U.S. Central Command, CENTCOM,
in the U.S. withdrawal in 2011, the subsequent
collapse of the Iraqi army in 2012 to ISIS.
So now look at the big picture. Not only are
you having to wave in a guy to recently in
the military to be traditionally eligible, you
have a guy who during his confirmation hearings
is going to be. On the receiving end of legitimate
criticisms for how he handled Iraq as well,
so sadly, there are people who are
going to listen to my entire story
and they're going to say, David, that's racist.
You don't want a black secretary of defense. No,
that's not what I said. If you're going to EEB,
don't even email me that. Don't even bother
emailing me that. And unfortunately, we will
lose subscribers. We will lose paid members.
Because I did this story because some people will
not focus on what I'm actually criticizing here,
which is that we are diversifying in terms of
identity, but perpetuating the exact problems
that we've been pointing out for more
than a decade at this point in time. So,
so far, Neera Tanden, disastrous pick, Lloyd
Austin, very problematic for the reasons that
I mentioned. These strike me as unforced errors.
If I'm missing something about this pick,
let me know. We'll have more coverage of this
on our Instagram at David Pakman show. And
I look forward to hearing your thoughts. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.